ist bereit der griechischer fruchtsaft
er wollte was gedacht und jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
wir sind immer noch hier in griechenland
und wenn die kamera wackelt wundert euch
nicht weil die steht auch um tisch
erstens ich weiß dieses feature das mir
viel zu groß ich hatte nur leider kein
anderes mehr
und zweitens probieren wir euch und
zweitens probieren wir heute griechische
süßigkeiten ich war gerade in der stadt
und habe ein bisschen rum geschaut und
habe einiges gefunden das haben wir ja
schon mit spanischen und chinesischen
und das war's und hier haben wir
insgesamt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 sachen zb dass
hier das fand ich so toll ja ich habe
insgesamt für die ganzen süßigkeiten 21
eur 50 bezahlt dass sie hat alleine vier
euro 90 gekostet
das fand ich schon echt viel in
deutschland hätte man so was vielleicht
zehn euro bezahlt oder höchstens gut das
war auch einem supermarkt in der stadt
aber trotzdem ich will gar nicht
eingeladen ich würde sagen wir fangen
sofort an und wenn ihr irgendwo hier
menschen reden hören solltet ist kein
problem das sind einfach unsere nachbarn
wo mittels nur anfangen was auch noch
kurz ganz lustig ist zu erwähnen wenn
man hier in griechenland so in
deutschland kennt man das ja wenn man so
sage ich einfach mal zwei euro
790 bezahlt 294 das duell wirklich zwei
euro 94 bezahlt und wenn du denn hier
drei euro gibt's kriegst du nicht sechs
cent zurück dass behalten die einfach
oder die geben die auch dann halt zb
mehr wieder
wobei gestern als ich denn ich habe
gestern so ein mann am chaos als ich dem
wasser geholt habe glaube ich hat der
280 und da habe ich gesagt drei europas
und da war richtig süß und das erst mal
gar nicht gecheckt und dann ja ich würde
sagen
hiermit an wir haben hier eu kanada
chuck ich kann mir das überhaupt nicht
legen
das ist ja auch komplett in anderen
buchstaben hier so sieht das aus ich
glaube das ist schade aber ich
vielleicht hier ländlichen eigentlich
normale schrift und die sport vernahm
ich glaube schon
so sieht's aus 10 3 mac eins zu eins die
schokolade auf einem deutschen
adventskalender
ich bin auch so einstellen dass ich
nicht so becking systems ist dass man
genau so ist das lecker hurrikan dadurch
es regnet heute einfach es war jeden tag
sonne und heute regnet sich zeigt euch
mal kurz sieht gleich ganz anders aus
hier also was trotzdem war das stimmt
also ich bin es lecker schmeckt ich
würde einfach mal sieben von zehn punkte
geben dafür herzlich komplett umgehauen
aber schmeckt wie typische vorgeladen
als nächstes würde ich sagen machen wir
mit einem getränk weiter und zwar haben
wir hier am etat das ist wohl ein
griechischer fruchtsaft brauchst ganz
viele lachen und menschen einzusenden
was einfach mal dass das hat ein euro
gekostet für 250 milliliter ist
natürlich auch nicht viel aber auch
nicht wenig wird als erstes probieren
weil du bist krank
ich habe mich übertrieben erklärte
[Musik]
das schmeckt fruchtig aber es schmeckt
nicht so intensiv fruchtig wie diese
deutschen getränke für mich ja stimmt
das kann auch sein
also man kann es auf jeden fall trinken
könnten treiber für das kennt und dann
kannst du das natürlich leer trinken von
mir wieder sieben punkte jetzt nichts
krasses aber es schmeckt auch okay als
nächstes haben wir von der gleichen
marke wie ich glaube das ist hier die
bekannteste marke in griechenland oder
so das müssen wir karamellbonbons sein
die sehen so aus ich liebe ja kam es in
deutschland deswegen bin ich mal
gespannt auf diese hier
der clevere idee einmal wichtig dass das
nicht zu hart ist wenn es zu habe ich
dann noch mal die zähne kaputt und das
bei mir diese ganzen parameter
frankreich die sind so hat die dinge man
weiß nicht so krass server los weil wir
reingehen
ich weiß nicht was gut sieht aber es ist
gerade rechnen
warum bist du so helfen die wahrheit und
ich denke wir sind jetzt gerade
eingegangen weil es draußen wirklich
extrem am rücken ist und genau jetzt hat
es eigentlich wieder aufgehört weil
machen jetzt kurz hier drinnen weiter
also waren wir den wagen audi
karamellbonbons in theorie dass das
licht jetzt so schlecht ist kriegt von
mir neun punkte kennt ihr die schreibt
in die kommentare
und hier war es okay ja weil das licht
so schlecht dass das packt mich richtig
ab und draußen kann man es nicht machen
weil die nachbarn so laut sind und weil
es regnet deswegen machen wir als
nächstes ist einfach den kakao
ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt was typisch
griechisches ist der sieht so aus ist
von der marke milko punkt ja das ist
griechisch müsste gestein ich mache den
man schnell auf und jetzt bin ich
gespannt weil ich finde eigentlich so
cacau aus flaschen meistens nicht so
lecker aber let's go der ist echt lecker
probieren
also aufpassen hat aber auch 250
gekostet oftmals hat man ja das problem
bei kakao dass er so künstlich schmeckt
der finde ich nicht also hier muss ich
wirklich sagen das wird gut umgesetzt
von der firma die haben sich gut
gedanken dazu gemacht haben die
passenden zutaten zusammen gemischt
eine gute reaktion hervorrufen was mich
dann natürlich sehr bewundern lässt
deswegen muss ich hier auf jeden fall
sagen von mir gibt es zehn punkte
den können wir ja so viel
als nächstes haben wir wir haben jetzt
noch die gummibärchen wir haben dieses
ding wir haben diese teile die brutal
teuer war und wir haben anita einstein
für die dinger diese langen teilen auch
mit kaufen können ja vielleicht kommen
diese langen dinger die man auf der
klima essen kann ja dann aus
griechenland eigentlich können jetzt
wieder rausgehen und es hat aufgehört zu
regnen ich will sich wieder alles
rundherum schleppen
aber das sind dann kommen wir gehen
wieder als zehn jahre später weiter
machen nachdem war eingeladen wurden
hier vom bei unserem nachbarn zum essen
wir haben jetzt noch drei sachen einmal
den satz dann einmal dieses milka ding
das ist von milka das ist jetzt
natürlich nichts typisch griechisch ist
aber ich habe das vorher entlassen
ja aber ihr habt in deutschland hat in
deutschland gibt es das nicht sicher und
listet auf ring ist ja okay das stimmt
lila pause ist gut wir probieren mal
kurz die lila pause die wahrscheinlich
nicht typisch griechisch ist aber warum
5 aber ich muss aufpassen wenn ich jetzt
weiter alles durcheinander also von mir
gibt es sechs punkte
das ist nicht so locker damals ist okay
fragt nicht nach deutschland zu kommen
jetzt sagen dass getränke kommen zum
schluss damit man was zum runterspülen
hatte und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt auf
die tollsten sachen liebe eingekauft
haben
jetzt bist du verlängert kennt ihr das
schreibt gerne in die kommentare es gibt
in deutschland auch mit oma hat ja ich
kann das auch das auch schon mal gesehen
ist bereit
ich probiere du als erstes 123 g ich
mache ich gern hab ich auch noch meine
oma gesucht hat ja ich aber ich war ein
bisschen anders bauen die nicht mehr es
mir wird schlecht ehrlich warum ich
wollte dass du keine ahnung jetzt mal
objektiv bewertet ohne dass mir davon
ein bisschen unwohl wird würde ich sagen
acht punkte das hier ist orangensaft er
schmeckt aber gar nicht gut an mietern
mieter
wir konnten uns für jeden morgen selbst
frischen orangensaft pressen der war
extrem lecker und sehr gesund
der schmeckt voll bitter und täglich
oder süßigkeiten haben wir auf jeden
fall für heute und morgen noch genug
diese teile bekommen von mir acht punkte
bekommen von mir zwei punkte ja leute
das waren ein paar griechische
süßigkeiten was würdest du jetzt zum
abschluss sagen waren die besser als die
spanischen oder die chinesischen die wir
gegessen haben also ich fand bis jetzt
glaube ich die spanischen am besten dann
die griechischen unternehmer sischen
also wenn ihr die spanischen und
chinesischen noch nicht gesehen habt
dann verlinke ich euch das natürlich am
ende schaut sich gerne an und ihr könnt
gerne in die kommentare schreiben in
welches land man auf jeden fall mal
fahren sollte um dort die süßigkeiten zu
probieren erreichte als nächstes
reiseziel oder so ansonsten war es mit
dem video schaut die gerne bei unseren
instagram account vorbei sind hier kurz
eingeblendet und ich wünsche euch noch
einen angenehmen tag
und morgen geht es auch wieder nach
hause nach deutschland wir waren jetzt
eine woche hier ist echt schön hier und
da willst du noch irgendwas sagen